herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
ich sitze hier heute zusammen in einer
bisher nie dagewesenen konstellation mit
meiner mama die links von der kamera
sitzt mein bruder und meiner kleinen
schwester die da schon die hände rein
hält
wir haben mit unseren namen 4 zettel
vorbereitet einmal mehr meine schwester
dann ich selbst unsere mama und
sebastian und wir spielen familien wer
würde er da ist ihr habt uns fragen
gestellt auf instagram und der wird
entscheiden wer die jeweiligen sachen am
ehesten machen würden was glaubst du
wirst was abbekommen
zum beispiel wer kann am schlechtesten
kochen sind natürlich alle mama die
antworten natürlich wahrheitsgemäß und
dementsprechend müssen wir bei so was
können wir da nicht unsere mama nehmen
weil die kocht ja sehr sehr gut
dann schau mal rein ich würde sagen die
erste frage lautet wer würde er mit
einer party das haus zerstört
georg kürzl bedenken 323 okay wir haben
es apple bertels apple-design sebastian
meine argumentation ich muss ich kurz
rechtfertigen wenn du so schockiert bist
meine argumentation tabea würde noch
nicht so große party feiern wo man was
kaputt macht
ich wäre zu ich wäre zu zu sorgen sagen
dass eigentlich mal an würde achten dass
nichts kaputt geht dass er beim ersten
mal
warum sagt sebastian
die haben dass apple das ist und vasen
party so der partie sah und das wort hat
mich die leute mit trash talk stimmt
natürlich nicht also was stimmt ist das
magazin maxim party machen würde der
würde gäste haben und die würden so am
eigenen sagen wer würde eher schlechte
noten schreiben wir sagen weil da sie
über die nachrede anzeige geht raus aber
okay ich bin schon nicht ich bin ja auch
in der siebten klasse sitzen geblieben
hat bisher als einziger sebastian hat
das eigentlich mache ich jetzt noch
bleibt mal sitzen auch sehr gute frage
wer würde er nackt auf die straße laufen
noch ganz schön ins schwitzen
[Musik]
ich habe zwei mal sowas ja mama hat sich
selbst glaube das lasse ich mal uns
kommuniziert und wir gehen zur nächsten
frage wer würde er für immer vegan leben
finde ich es muss sehr interessante
frage war ja auch hier 321 das ist
absolut falsch war was du hast du hast
machst du hast doch schon so oft
überlegt zum veganen monat oder so zu
machen auch jaja aber langfristig glaube
ich wäre mama da am ersten für zu
gewinnen kannst du dich eigentlich macht
reifen die in block 3
sie sagt das machen wir gerne mal drei
von vier haben wir mal gestimmt ich
glaube also allein entscheiden aber ich
glaube schon am ersten wärst du dass man
mal weil du könntest du wärst du nicht
so koch foul das ist ein problem für
dich werden können ist jetzt die sie
dann leckere begaben sachen auch kochen
jetzt also ok willkommen zur nächsten
frage wer würde er den geburtstag eines
familienmitglieds vergessen alle alle
außer mama ich hab drei der meinung kann
nicht sagen wann aber ist meine ich habe
schon mal geburtstag vergessen und nicht
diejenigen die euch an dieser stelle
sagen mit einer wiederholten
öffentlichen entschuldigung an unseren
papa
wir haben nämlich alle drei einmal
seinen geburtstag vergessen habe ich
habe es mir gesagt und ich habe es dann
euch gesagt da haben wir nicht vergessen
aber es gibt da passt gut zu verteidigen
aber nein wir haben ich habe einen tag
später geht weil ich wirklich auf
facebook gesehen habe dass ihm leute
gratuliert haben also wir müssen leider
sagen wirklich super schlechteren kurz
tage zu behalten und wir sind recht
herzlich zu gratulieren
überhaupt wenn jedes jahr geburtstag zu
sagen wir ganz okay auch wieder richtung
party wäre würde er heimlich eine house
party schmeißen
jetzt hab ich keine kommentare okay bin
gespannt sie selbst mama bereit
bitte sagen alle bis auf
wir also house party machen mein konto
zurück nach dem urlaub also wir drei mal
im urlaub oder zu hause die bude ist
zerstört überall porzellan und also habe
ja so eine party geschmissen was wir
können das heißt weiß nicht wann mein
tor habe ich eine party das mega frage
auch wer würde er alles stehen und
liegen lassen um auszuwandern
wir haben quasi dreimal bär und zweimal
markus leuthe und manchmal wir doppelt
bestimmt es vettel nicht gegolten
erklärte
also ich habe mich genommen weil
deutschland einfach scheiße ist und sich
eigentlich nach amerika will auch zum
studieren deswegen hat man
wahrscheinlich sprechen 14 jahre lebens
ich hab mein gott wirklich aus dem weg
zur schule abgestochen wir lagen jedoch
nicht erschossen
ich muss alle leute gerade so kurz
kommen umbringen und habe machst
genommen weil max kreis am liebsten und
macht es so der letzte der so wenn man
in einem hotel außerhalb sagen würde
glauben zu sagen würde ich will wieder
nach hause und war so ist halt schon
sehr an zu hause und max kommt ja nie
und mama ist halt zu hause da wurde ich
kurz geschadet wahrheit gar nicht ob das
so gut ist dass wird es hier diese
fragen beantwortet sie geht hier direkt
in familien psychologie im spiel nach
ein kleines spiel okay
die faktenlage ist eindeutig aber ich
bin auf die antworten gespannt wer würde
er sich aussperren
ich weiß ich habe jemals wird ein
schlüssel gehabt und so nachbarn haben
schlüsselwerk ganz räder nicht
ausbleiben wie hast du dich selbst
genommen hat mich in meiner kurzen zeit
in köln viermal ausgesperrt und musste
den schlüsseldienst nicht bei den köln
ich habe mich hier schon mehrfach hat
die tür zugemacht dafür selber drin
viermal im jahr locker du kannst dich
aber auch wer würde er das essen von
einem anderen essen und es dann auch
nochmals jemand anderen schieben also
zum beispiel sebastian ist ein essen und
sagt ja was ist also diese zum beispiel
14 punkte wäre einer der sebastianer
sich gegeben hat ich glaube sebastian
würde definitiv leuten was weg essen
aber er wird würde dann einfach so
packen kreis sagen ich gegessen was
heißt 30 stehe dazu aber heute wäre aber
so weiter was ich habe schon vergessenes
von zwei stunden war okay darüber darf
man glaube ich nicht weiter nachdenken
wer würde er max kruse ablecken
ok ich hab' ja ich würde doch er selbst
als dass irgendjemand anderes
warum gelingt warum hast du diese frage
überhaupt wäre der essen bestellen
anstatt es selbst zu machen
nein ich koche auch selbst gar nicht du
hat selbst gesagt dass du wenn du so
fitness fassen was da kommst du selbst
aber noch gesunden ja du gehst du
gestellt seien nicht du bist halt essen
ja okay dann nämlich max raus aber von
welchem geld gestellt zu dem essen unter
weg von daheim weiteres geld besteht in
österreich essen bestellt haben und dann
hat es mir auf dem band
also du bist genau womit angebrachte
weil wir sind aus köln gekommen 200
stunden fahrt in unserer heimat kommen
an gleichzeitig mit uns steht da so ein
pizzabote an der tür
wie gehen sie zur tür rein unsere
sprecher könnt ihr das bezahlen ich habe
kein geld
danke für diese frage so viel würde er
geschirr stehen lassen zb sattelmaier
also wer also leute werden sagen sollte
ein nähe von euch da draußen vorher mit
maximal zusammen zu ziehen macht sie
nicht max ist so ein kranker nazi alter
was ordnung angeblich ich trinke so
kaffee
stell dir vor stellt die tasse ab für
eine sekunde max das ist eine wahre
meine wahrnehmung ist dass eine wohnung
innerhalb von kürzester zeit im müll
verwandelt wer würde er einen monat lang
nur dort werde er als erstes ins bett
gehen ja jemand um 19 uhr schlafen wir
haben um 8 uhr
aber ich habe ich nämlich an sich um
dich zu wissen weil es manchmal wenn wir
nichts mit max feiern gehen will were
ich bin so etwas will
wir gehen um einen oder ist wo es zum
feiern das wäre würde er etwas aus
tollpatschigkeit zerstören
wer wäre wäre aber natürlich versehen
mit dem klasse und die letzte frage
lautet wer würde er einen absturz auf
alkohol haben absturz dass man nicht
mehr denkt dass man fit ist und
zumal wenn sie nicht ab wir reden über
heute also mit heutigen zustand also
nicht mehr dass man in der vergangenheit
gemacht hat so wäre dann wäre es wird
wenn es jetzt am ehesten passieren würde
3 das wird ja ich glaub ihr studium
zügig haben genug training mittlerweile
dass uns das nicht mehr passiert ich
sehe wurde einschätzen dachte ich auch
immer wieder okay leute dann dank habe
ich einen dass sie dabei war zwar recht
richtig lustig macht viel spaß und der
runde - aufzunehmen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder haut rein und
macht